[Music]
this scene when Joe first walks in he
knows exactly what's going on up there
these incredible mood swings it's so
routine in their life grey the way it's
written she's not crying quite that hard
but because I know as an actor that the
house is dark and Todd's going to be
following um Charles in as he comes that
that signals to me I it's going to be
bigger like it feels to me like I'm like
oh then I'm starting because she's
throwing
it's like you're not waiting for
somebody to find you you're sending out
the signal like listen to me I'm up here
what happened all of that tension
contributes to the size of her breakdown
joy and Mur called a cancel her order
and all future orders it's an excited
sigh because thank God Gracie didn't see
me with Elizabeth walking kind of
opening up for the first time I wasted
hours that I could have used you could
have have known graci to me this whole
scene is about the time of day and you
feel it in the dress color and the color
of the bed spread and the color of the
headboard I mean this scene doesn't work
without that sense of that Tamp down
intensity of color I just I hate things
like that and now I have this cake
that's going to go right in the Garment
you don't have to do it in the I
got a little tear eye because I was so
moved when we rehearsed I couldn't
believe it and then I just found myself
going to the bed and like consoling you
where were
you I took a walk showed Elizabeth and
neighborhood it's all about Elizabeth of
course it's about Elizabeth and it's
about the fragility of the whole life
being in Peril yeah exactly but it's
like she uses all these other things as
the ways that we cope
Elizabeth he's getting on my last nerve
and the Elizabeth's getting on my last
nerve because what it is is that
encroachment on her life it gets too
much it's just too much you can't bear
it she just everywhere I look for what
for the
movie so people can see it and
understand more this dress is called the
nap dress I love it because it is so
like I said she looks like a doll you
know this is a woman who wants to dress
like a doll like a like a like a child
and maybe it's more easier for you this
role of Joe was so pivotal to how this
film ultimately works for
me for
us for both of us in Charles's
performance I saw something I saw in
nobody else and it was this sense of
scale in his approach like somebody who
you saw the history of this character in
that performance I can see the
past I don't know and I can see the
present she'll be gone
soon you realize this man has had to
recalibrate his expectations around how
she is always distancing herself from
her own feelings I ate so much of that
cake youe a lot of that and then I drink
that milk in one of those takes that
whole glass of milk I was like yum it's
good it was serving your role
all that all that all those calories it
was it was I needed it yeah so
good this particular day which was one
of our hardest days of production
because of the number of extras and
because it was that late in the day we
got the most extraordinary light the
script always ended at graduation it was
always I think described as two generals
kind of meeting on the battlefield in
white
that beautiful wasn't it it was this is
the example of working with actors like
this where you literally have no time we
use the first the single First Take of I
love what Natalie does in this it's so
beautiful and so subtle and so aware
well heading to the airport now it's
probably for the best I love that
description of the battlefields cuz it
really does feel like disarming like
it's you completely disarmed me in it
and and we've got the the glasses are
sort of like our armor yeah I wonder if
any of this will have really mattered
for your movie I was lucky that part of
my character was studying her because
that's what I was doing in real life I
was just like watching and going how she
doing that this is another example of
how comfortable I felt you know on this
movie and with
Natalie that when you have that kind of
rapport with another actor and that kind
of partnership then Everything feels so
easy you understand
me I do one of the great things about
the writing is that you're constantly
kind of Shifting who you're with
emotionally who you're seeing everything
through and at this moment it's like
another final shift where you think you
know what you feel and then it goes
uh-uh I hope you didn't think that
disgusting brother thing was real
Elizabeth finally what she thinks gotten
this inner core that she's built when
she speaks to to Gracie's son from her
first marriage Georgie and he tells her
that she's been a victim herself and
there's this moment that she sort of
lets her off the hook and and I think
the audience does too I think there's an
okay that makes sense
disgusting I don't know what he's doing
telling you these
things he told you I talk to Georgie
every day in a story that is aens L
about truth seeking and finding the
truth which is what Elizabeth claims as
her mission right that what is so
fascinating about the dynamic of the of
the two women and the power play that
keep shifting between them is that it's
all when Gracie says and she just said
in the previous scene I'm naive I always
have that in many ways it's a gift and
here she says insecure people are very
dangerous aren't they and you realize
that's the one who gains the power m is
the person who blocks the you think the
power is on on the side of Truth seeking
in fact it's the person who puts up the
wall I'm
secure make sure you put that in
there it's all performance when you
think that you have no control except
for these narratives that you've created
which is why I think we love movies so
much because there's a beginning a
middle and an
[Music]
end